Um,
okay.
So thanks everyone for coming.
My name is Vira,
uh,
myself and Vern,
head up toxic Google for the Toronto office.
This is our second installment.
Um,
we're sticking on this charity train.
I love it very much.
Um,
so we have doctors,
Samantha Nutt from or child here with us today.
Adam Green,
as you all know who's from the agency team is the,
um,
creative lead.
He will be hosting.
And uh,
welcome.
Thank you for coming.
If you do have any questions,
please walk up to the mix as there are people on the live stream and we are
recording this.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Thanks [inaudible] and welcome.
Thank you.
Excellent.
Thanks for coming into Google.
Um,
so for those who aren't familiar with your work,
if you could tell us a little bit about what is war child,
um,
and,
and the work that you guys do around the world.
So we're told is an international nongovernmental organization and charity and
we work with children and their families on the front lines of most of the
world's most,
uh,
significant and intense conflicts.
So essentially what we are is we're a protection agency.
So we go into environments to work with those kids and their families to make
sure that they are safe,
that their needs are being met and that they have opportunities to rebuild their
lives and rebuild their communities over the long term.
The ways in which we do that,
we kind of what we focused on,
we have three pillars.
So one is education,
making sure that kids in war are allowed to uh,
maintain their education,
catch up on their education and grow to be thriving members of their community.
The second part of what we do,
it sounds a little bit technical,
but it's justice work.
And so we make sure that especially in environments where girls and young boys
can be,
um,
you know,
sexually assaulted whether whites are routinely being violated.
A,
we work to actually promote an uphold the rule of law by training lawyers and
paralegals,
uh,
defending the rights of those children actively within those communities,
but also through the legal infrastructure if one exists.
And then the third part of what we do,
we call opportunity,
which is really about making sure that families are economically self reliant.
And have the opportunity to provide for themselves to try to break that cycle of
aid dependency that plagues so many humanitarian catastrophes around the world.
But just making sure that those families have resources at their own disposal
disposal to be able to make the right kinds of decisions that will be suitable
for them and for their children.
Just fantastic work.
Thank you.
Um,
so you,
you work in some of the most miserable and dangerous places in the world.
Places where,
uh,
there is effective we active work going on and most of what we hear is how do
they get emergency aid and have sutures enough water and a plasma in there.
How do you guys get in books and lawyers and,
and actually work with people on building longer,
better lives?
Oh,
I think Adam,
you've hit on a really good point,
which is that when we think about crises in other parts of the world and
especially war,
unfortunately our memories are pretty short,
right?
And so we think about the emergency phase.
So food,
water,
shelter,
blankets,
vaccination programs,
the things that you need to give to keep people alive.
Um,
but people also need reasons to live.
And when wars drag on as they so frequently do,
if you look at the word Syria now,
it's in its sixth year.
The war in Sudan has been apart from a few moments where it hasn't been as
intense,
has been going on for many decades now.
Uh,
other parts of the Middle East.
If you look at eastern Congo where it's nearly 20 years,
Somalia where it's multiple decades,
uh,
as those wars drag on those gaps in those needs become that much more enormous.
And unfortunately,
our capacity to remain involved and demonstrate compassion tends to dwindle as
those conflicts drag on.
Um,
and,
and unfortunately that's when the needs become even greater because you've got
kids that have been out of school for five,
six,
10 years.
You've got families that have completely drained,
uh,
all of their financial resources that have lost their land,
lost their livelihoods are you have a,
a legal infrastructure,
a protective environment that has essentially been destroyed where there may not
be any police,
there may not be a functioning judicial infrastructure.
So if your rights are being violated,
if you're being raped and abused,
you have no recourse.
And so that's what war child focuses on.
And,
and in order to do that,
you have to mobilize those local communities.
You have to make sure that they have the skills and the capacity to be able to
do the work that they have,
the resources.
And fundamentally you have to make sure that they,
that you have a longterm vision.
War is a long term problem.
And by continuing to only plug those gaps,
uh,
we,
we aren't,
I think fundamentally addressing the,
the reasons why some of these communities tend to be locked in that cycle of
violence and poverty and frankly despair in the first place.
So you mentioned the war in the Congo.
Um,
we had the good fortune of having Malala usef size parents here,
uh,
the other week.
And he mentioned that,
um,
the children that are sitting in camps today getting no education,
uh,
they are the isis of tomorrow.
They are the wars of tomorrow.
Uh,
they're the terrorists.
If tomorrow the DRC came through one of the worst,
worst in modern history,
uh,
there are an estimated seven and a half million kids there who are getting no
no education.
Um,
is that really the demographic time bomb that,
that uh,
the Malala was dad was,
was fearing.
Certainly it is,
it is true that kids who have almost nothing in environments where there is a
tremendous amount of violence where there's recruitment that's going on by
various armed groups,
militia groups.
Uh,
in the case in the Congo,
it's,
it's an,
an inordinate number of people that are a recruiting and abducting young people
to fight,
uh,
in that conflict,
in a climate of,
of absolute impunity.
So certainly young people who are unemployed,
who are not in school,
who have witnessed horrific abuses,
who had been the victims of horrific abuses themselves,
they are certainly more vulnerable to that level of recruitment to that kind of,
um,
ideological pole that many of those armed groups we'll offer them.
I mean,
we know,
we're told,
knows even from the work that we've done all around the world,
that when we have done skills training with young people,
when we have worked with teachers and other educators to make sure that they had
access to education could go back to school at an appropriate grade level.
Because if you're 17,
you've been fighting with the militia group in eastern Congo and you're
functionally illiterate,
you don't want to go back to being in grade one with a bunch of six year olds.
I mean,
that's humiliating for you.
So that becomes a huge barrier.
So yes,
education is critically important.
It's not the only thing though economic development,
it becomes critically important.
Um,
and making sure that their psychological needs are being addressed.
And,
and that overarching framework of,
of,
uh,
of a lack of accountability is one of the biggest challenges too.
Yeah.
You're making your book a pretty strong case that in the Venn diagram of
humanity where cheap,
small arms and idle young men intersect is a recipe for war.
So educating,
uh,
bring education in hopefully pulls the,
the idle young men,
uh,
out of that equation.
But how far can you get when AK 47?
This costs $10 in a lot of these places,
education is a huge part.
What about arms control?
Okay.
Uh,
arms control is absolutely critical and I think that there is,
uh,
it's especially important right now that we talk about this issue.
You know,
when you look at the,
the rise of Isis in the Middle East,
if you look at even the devastating attacks that have taken place in the United
States,
um,
even in Orlando,
Florida,
the,
uh,
easy availability of automatic and semiautomatic weapons,
small arms more generally,
um,
creates both opportunity and means for those who seek to destroy and harm,
uh,
to be able to do so.
And the proliferation of small arms,
especially in unstable environments is,
I think one of the single greatest threats to public health and global peace and
security in existence in the world.
Today,
we have seen a dramatic increase in the sale of those arms,
uh,
in the manufacturing of those weapons since September 11th,
over the past more,
you know,
now more than 15 years.
Um,
and so if you have a lawless environment where there is very little employment,
where you've got half the population roughly that is,
uh,
under the age of 30,
and in some cases under the age of 18,
you know,
you are going to have a situation where people will take up arms to resolve
grievances,
uh,
to earn an income and uh,
and,
and enter express their will and their particular ideology.
So,
so the arms,
uh,
in and of themselves,
I mean,
it's that adding that into the equation,
um,
is one of the hardest issues to address in a war zone.
You have to,
disarmament is absolutely critical to peace and prosperity.
And a lot of the talk about,
about our Roman revolves around the locations where the arms are,
but most of those guns are not coming from sub Saharan Africa or the Middle
East.
They're manufactured within a couple of hundred kilometers of where we're
sitting right now.
The United States is the largest arms exporter in the world and very recently
with the lab deal in Saudi Arabia,
Canada.
Hey,
had the dubious distinction of being declared the number two arms dealer.
Yeah.
Um,
so does that talk need to have a here usually when we talk about arms control
and proliferation,
it's a,
on the nuclear scale,
like our,
our is tend to be obsessed with state versus state conflict.
Uh,
we're spending $1 trillion on the next fighter jet programme,
the f 35,
that's the entire aid budget of the world,
roughly the NGO budget.
Uh,
when,
at what point does arms control,
need to start talking about like 20 caliber things that did sit in a,
in a,
in someone's purse in Texas,
but then can be used to end dozens of lives in somewhere like Sierra Leone.
Well,
thank you.
Bastards are multiple pieces to that.
To that question.
Um,
which is a,
I think a very,
very important one.
Uh,
you know,
on the issue of,
uh,
small arms being available and accessible,
you know,
the problem with small arms,
many of them look at the coalition,
the cough rifle,
they are virtually in distractible.
They are the preferred weapon.
Yeah.
I need to be buried in sand.
So if you make it here,
you make it to the United States or it's made in Russia or in China or wherever
else,
once it gets into an international market,
that is rarely it's last stop.
And some of the ones that I have seen,
uh,
and frankly some of the ones that have been pointed at me over the years,
by young men have been weapons that were made even in the fifties and sixties.
They are,
they're very easy for kids to load and reload in to be trained to you.
So,
so any weapon like that,
that enters the marketplace,
um,
it is a permanent problem and it's not a temporary problem.
So that's,
that's one piece of it in terms of,
uh,
who contributes to that.
If you look at all weapons sales,
so we,
that includes everything.
Roughly 80% of all weapons that are sold in the world,
um,
are manufactured by the United States,
has roughly half,
but then usually it's England,
Germany,
France,
Russia,
China.
So roughly 80% of them come from none other than the five permanent members,
United Nations Security Council,
plus Germany.
Uh,
unfortunately,
now Canada is inching into that,
that equation.
Um,
and I think it's something that we have to consider very,
very,
very carefully because it does,
I think,
undermine our international reputation.
And we as Canadians can sometimes,
you know,
we think that we're the world's peacekeepers.
Um,
and then we have this reputation around the world of human rights says,
yeah,
and we're,
and we're not that anymore.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
if we,
if we want to have kind of prominence on the world stage and that credibility
and that reputation,
uh,
then I personally think that we have to,
to really question whether or not our,
our arms exports are consistent with that value of promoting a,
or those values of promoting peace and security and human rights.
Because you can go to any war zone around the world and know that that is not
the case.
So until we can do that is do you feel like you like you guys at war channel to
kind of bailing the titanic with a bucket,
um,
as you try to educate people out of this,
but,
but almost unlimited free weapons are coming in the other side?
I think I would look at that metaphor slightly differently.
I feel like sometimes you're on the deck of the titanic and you can see the
iceberg.
You know,
you see kids in,
in Syrian refugees living in camps,
uh,
who are becoming increasingly despondent because they don't have the
opportunity.
You see a southern Sudanese families who are selling their children into two
arms groups because they've run out of resources and because they're
increasingly desperate.
So you feel like you're on the deck of the titanic,
you can see the iceberg and you're going to have a name,
see iceberg the iceberg.
Right.
And,
and,
um,
and yet it's not enough to change course.
And,
and that's the part that's incredibly frustrating for me.
Um,
and I think for us as an organization,
because you,
uh,
you can,
you can feel it on the ground when it's happening.
You can feel that shift,
that,
that moment when people transition from being hopeful too,
that sense of hopelessness,
that sense that the world has forgotten them,
that nobody cares about what's happening to them.
Um,
that when,
that,
when that anger and that resentment begin to build a,
when they feel increasingly desperate and,
and it's no surprise then that almost a year within that moment,
you start to see people putting their toddlers on,
into rubber dinghies and trying to,
uh,
make it across the Mediterranean Sea to get them to safety.
Um,
yeah.
When that's the best,
that's not for your family,
you know,
things are,
are unspeakably horrible.
That's right.
That's the problem.
So your,
your book is full of unbelievably harrowing stories,
uh,
things that you've gone through.
One of the things that struck me was the number of whip smart,
incredibly brave,
uh,
educated women from around the world that you've worked with,
who've met with horrible,
untimely ends.
Um,
you make a really good case for the education of,
of women and girls around the world.
As a father of two little girls,
I don't even think it's,
it's up for debate.
Um,
but how risky is it as we educate them or we are we sending more people to the
slaughter if we're not educating people on the other side,
uh,
educating the angry young men with a $10 automatic rifles,
as to what society should,
could and should look like if everyone was equal.
Both.
You don't have to do one at the exclusion of others.
So educating girls doesn't mean that that comes at the expense of educating
boys.
And,
and we found that more.
Todd's found that with our work all around the world,
if you're not investing in,
I will be called community based sensitization going into those communities,
talking about the value of girls' education,
demonstrating the importance of,
of women's economic empowerment,
proving that to those communities by having those women return.
Um,
and they do become very productive members and,
and slowly you see people's minds and attitudes change.
And you can't go in there with this,
with this giant sort of imperialistic agenda and your finger wagging and saying,
it's gotta be this way.
And that's wrong because if you do that,
you're going to be shut out and shut down.
And you may in fact put many of those young girls,
women that you want to be helping at risk by virtue of,
of behaving in that fashion.
There's been some of that Madonna had,
uh,
there has been speculation effort that did end it in,
in flames and Oprah and,
and a few others.
Um,
you're pretty,
you offers some pretty withering criticism in your book of people who just come
in with an outside agenda into a local area,
uh,
and say like,
this is how it should be.
How do you guys operate differently in war child?
How do you make sure you're not doing that?
Well for us,
our 98% of our staff are local,
so,
and we have several hundred staff around the world.
So these are folks who come from war zones who are working for us within those
countries to build our programs,
to identify the needs,
to evaluate them,
to make sure that we're asking the right questions and that we have that level
of,
of community legitimacy and acceptance before we even start a weird less,
I said we're not an emergency organization,
so we don't go in there and say,
well,
we're in the business of blankets,
so here's your blanket.
Um,
that's not what we do.
We go in,
we will have a one two year process of,
of information gathering,
of collaboration,
of conversation with local community groups,
grassroots civil society organizations,
UN agencies,
other organizations on the ground to say,
okay,
what contribution can we make here?
What are the needs?
What needs are not being met?
What is the overall risk to children in that community by not meeting those
needs?
And how can we help you?
And I think that that fundamentally is the question.
If you go in and say,
this is how we're going to help you,
that's how aid goes wrong.
If you go in and say,
um,
tell me about what's going on here.
How can we help you and you and you build it.
And you were critical in that process and ask yourself the hard questions.
It doesn't mean you'll always get it right,
but it means you're more likely to get it right
to come with more,
more question marks,
less exclamation points.
Absolutely.
And you see that in a lot of crises.
You see a lot of grandstanding.
Um,
and for me over the years,
you know,
I've been doing this work for 20 years,
it's,
it's kind of been the bane of my existence.
People who have no experience in Iraq and then they've been there for two days
and they stand up and they say,
children are starving here.
And you look at them and you go,
where the hell have you been?
Yes.
They have been starving here for the last 10 years.
Actually,
thanks to sanctions.
But uh,
yeah,
welcome.
Yeah,
this baseball game for awhile.
That's right.
Um,
you,
you also offer some,
some pretty uh,
heavy criticism of,
of well meaning do gooders how can we in in the privilege to West help folks
that did actually is productive.
You,
you're pretty critical of things like voluntourism um,
of,
of Ping Pong ball funding where you find a government that funds the UN that the
infants,
their local region that then funds in Ngo and by the time someone in need
actually gets the money,
it's like small pennies on the dollar.
What can we do that's actually effective from this end?
Well,
there,
there are a number of things.
I mean the more directly you can contribute to an organization that is working
on the ground with those grassroots partners,
that means that your money is going to go much further.
So every time if you're Canadian organization that then has their national arm
and then it gets kind of divided and divided and divided and then it will end up
at the field level,
uh,
the impact of your dollar is diluted.
So that's something to be very mindful of is to always make sure that,
ask organizations what is their programming model?
Are they a directly implementing agency?
Because that's uh,
that's very,
very,
very critical.
The second piece of it is,
you know,
so much of our aid money is wasted because of one thing.
And that one thing is inconsistency.
Because we see a crisis in the news.
We might write a check once or go online and donate and then here we are five,
six,
seven years later going,
well,
why don't things get any better in places like Haiti?
I mean these kinds of challenges,
you're really talking about structural deficits and like anything else,
it takes time.
And so we know here,
if you're talking about education,
it's not enough to send a kid to school for a week or month or even a year.
It is a long term investment.
So you are far better off as a donor giving a,
and this is always when my director of development has a heart attack,
but um,
he's been,
now he's going don't say this,
but you are far better off giving a smaller amount of money on a regular basis.
Then you are writing a check once and then and then forgetting about it.
It allows organizations to properly plan to implement in areas that the world
has often forgotten and is showing less interest in.
It allows you to direct the those resources to the highest need environments and
not be so subjected to the whims and mercies of the media cycle,
for example.
So that's one way to do it.
You know,
don't give things like a hard goods,
clothes and books and all that stuff.
It won't get there in time to be useful.
It's too expensive to ship and distributed cash flies a lot.
Chief ash is a lot better,
you know,
it's a much better way of doing it.
And in fact,
many organizations now are looking at cash vouchers for refugees because then
they can make their own decisions around,
uh,
what their family needs.
And we have this very paternalistic approach.
It's like,
no,
you're going to have 10 bags of rice and six blankets.
And a lot of those refugee families are saying,
they're saying,
actually I don't eat rice and I got enough blankets,
but yeah,
that's how we do it.
Right?
And,
and so now we're changing that attitude and,
and making it a little bit more,
um,
uh,
certainly more,
but also recognizing the value of cash contributions and,
and labor.
Um,
you know,
gifts in kind like labor are extremely valuable,
especially to organizations that might have headquarters locally.
You know,
people have various skills that they can bring to our organization.
But that volunteer work is most helpful to us here.
Unless you are a seasoned expert who understands development,
understands the context,
understands the risks involved.
Frankly,
when you're going overseas and doing this kind of work,
you might be taking those opportunities away from local community groups,
which is something to be mindful of.
A lot of it is busy work,
philanthropy,
do you really need to go and we paid that classroom?
Or is there somebody else that with the money you save on your ticket could be
hired.
It's a local pay that to,
to paint that classroom.
Right?
Um,
and then the second piece of it is it's a,
it's a huge security risk for most agencies.
So sometimes the better way for you to contribute,
in fact,
every way,
often the better way to contribute is,
is to be a donor and to help,
uh,
here if you can.
Excellent.
Um,
so I want to bring it back to Google for a second.
We have this mantra.
Don't be evil.
We all like to think of ourselves as really good people.
Uh,
but pretty much all of us have a tiny slice of unspeakable evil sitting in our
pocket right now.
The minerals that go into these,
particularly Colt and mine in the DRC is,
uh,
an engine of human misery.
Why do you think the industry collective,
we can't,
can't get on top of that.
We did it with diamonds.
Uh,
why not other minerals?
It's a lot more complicated than diamonds.
Um,
and I'm not offering that up as an excuse but more of a,
of an explanation.
I mean,
you can take a diamond and look at it,
uh,
under a microscope and know exactly where it came from.
And so conflict tracing in that sort of environment became a somewhat easier
within with Colton.
I mean quilting,
uh,
it's estimated that the Congo contains between 60 to 80% of the world's coal tan
deposits.
It is readily smuggled across Congos border is,
it ends up in international markets.
Um,
it,
it generates hundreds of millions of dollars in revenues and a often used
towards arms sales,
uh,
for various Congolese back military groups and militia groups operating in that
unstable part of the world.
But by the time it gets to your cell phone,
you have no idea whether it's Congolese,
cold,
Tan or any other kind of cool 10,
chances are just based on probability.
It is Congolese,
Cool Tan.
Um,
I think,
you know,
to be honest,
this is an issue that the industry itself needs to actively get behind and start
to look at what solutions are,
are viable,
uh,
and make the most sense at a straight out ban.
Uh,
unfortunately,
you know,
it follows the law of unintended consequences.
And under the Dodd frank legislation in the United States,
um,
they required more sort of more accountability and companies not to use conflict
minerals.
Um,
what result,
what happened was a lot of American firms close their minds that put a lot of
our teams will miners out of work.
Um,
and what happens when have no employment?
You join a militia group because they are the only employer.
So again,
the law is an unintended consequences.
What we really need is,
is sectoral reform.
We need to look at how you fix the climate of impunity.
At the same time,
you have to come at it from a number of different,
uh,
perspectives.
It can be done,
but none of that will ever happen unless one other thing happens.
And that's that the industry itself has to be prepared to confront this in an,
in an honest and transparent way.
The tech industry or the mining industry,
the entire industry,
tech and mining,
because the two really go hand in hand,
right?
We're at a big tech company and within 10 block radius of this office is the
highest concentration of Mining Hump Company headquarters in the world.
So we might be in this office somewhat uniquely placed to tackle this issue.
You are uniquely placed to tackle this issue.
And,
and,
and every time any effort has been brought about to introduce legislation,
um,
around this,
that would force frankly mining companies to be more accountable and
transparent.
It's been met by very heavy lobbying,
uh,
expensive lobbying on the part of those mining industries.
And it has been shut down and I will see,
see 300 guns very narrowly though.
It was only like 10 votes.
And then,
and then Paul dewar.
Yeah,
I was trying to introduce legislation as well,
who is the NDP foreign affairs critic who lost his seat recently in the
election.
But,
um,
he also had,
uh,
taken steps around this issue.
And again,
I don't want to,
you know,
it's not the,
the answers are not simple.
Um,
it does need a development approach.
It needs a governance approach.
Uh,
it needs a diplomatic approach.
Um,
but all of that can happen as long as there is acknowledgement from the industry
and a willingness to lead change and a,
and if you could,
if we can even start there and begin to have those conversations,
recognize that we have a real problem.
And that's exactly what happened with conflict diamonds for a while.
The industry was like,
there isn't a problem.
There isn't a problem.
And they ran from it and they lobbied against it.
And then finally they said,
we do have a problem.
The Kimberley Process is imperfect.
Uh,
the fact that Zimbabwean diamonds were not considered conflict.
Diamonds is a huge gaping hole right in that process,
but it's a step in the right direction.
And even if it's imperfect to start,
at least,
at least we're making that effort.
Yeah.
Do something,
something is better than something is usually better than nothing usually.
Usually.
That's fine.
Um,
so I want to get,
I want to change gears a little link and go to you personally.
You're a physician,
an author,
as an assistant professor at the u of t,
uh,
a mother,
a board member,
and the founder and executive director of World Child Canada.
I,
and you're also in the midst of setting up,
workout us.
When exactly do you sleep
between three and five in the morning?
No.
Uh,
sleep is overrated.
Is it not?
No,
it's not.
It is a glorious,
glorious part of life.
You should try it more off.
No one is claiming I'm doing all of those things by the way.
Um,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's one of those things and,
and this is going to sound so trite and I apologize in advance,
but,
um,
when you do what you love,
there really is no distinction between your on time and your off time.
Right?
So when I'm reading,
I'm reading about foreign policy and global issues.
When I'm have it sitting around the dinner table,
we're discussing and debating these issues and,
and you know,
and I have a limitless passion for the work that war child does around the
world.
And so,
um,
not championing that,
uh,
it feels like,
you know,
like I'm just being disconnected from myself in many ways.
So,
so it's about,
uh,
for me,
I don't,
I'm not tired by what I do.
I'm energized by it.
I get more tired when I'm,
when I'm not doing it.
When I feel that,
um,
you know,
I,
I haven't done enough and,
uh,
that's when I feel most frustrated.
It's like the ultimate substitute for coffee for you.
It is.
Yes.
It does.
Well,
or coffee or,
or,
uh,
yeah,
no,
it's,
it's just,
um,
I was gonna say wine there,
but,
but I still liked my wife.
Um,
the,
that's right.
That's right.
No,
it's,
I'm,
I'm lucky I get to do and I'm passionate about and we can't all say that in
life.
That's fantastic.
Uh,
do,
do you guys have any questions in the audience?
I want to be cognizant and not just hog the mic the whole time.
Uh,
you know,
Margo,
just go up to that,
the Mike if you can't,
if you're on.
Um,
you talked a little bit earlier about,
um,
Canadians perception as being peacekeepers.
Uh,
when the reality is,
is that we are a big part in a growing part of the distribution of weapons.
I'm curious if you've had a chance to sit down with our relatively new
government,
um,
Prime Minister Trudeau or anybody in his,
in his circle and what their view is on where we are today and trying to correct
some of these issues that we might be contributing towards.
That's an excellent question.
And,
uh,
I have had some of those conversations and they are certainly ongoing.
Um,
and I am,
uh,
testified at the Standing Committee on foreign affairs over the last couple of
years and a few of these related issues.
I think one of the most significant things so that Canada can do and should be
doing is signing the arms trade treaty.
Um,
the arms trade treaty was initially a Canadian led effort to try to bring about
international binding legislation concerning the sale,
the manufacturing,
the stockpiling and the transfer of small and light weapons in the world.
And,
uh,
about two years ago now,
in fact,
it finally passed to the United Nations and more than 115 countries have signed
onto it.
Uh,
unfortunately along with Russia and China,
Canada has not yet signed the arms trade treaty and because we missed the first,
now we have to pass a whole series of pieces of legislation before we're even
eligible to sign it.
Um,
and there is a,
and I'm going to be very,
very clear on this.
Uh,
one point there is no way that if we had signed the arms trade treaty,
we would have been able to approve that $15 billion arms deal to Saudi Arabia or
to Thailand subsequently.
So,
um,
now
the current government has committed to signing the arms trade treaty,
but there has been no official deadline,
uh,
prescribed in relation to that.
Um,
and because it,
it is contingent upon these other pieces of legislation falling into place,
uh,
I don't know how long that's going to take or if he's even going to be during
this particular parliamentary cycle.
I,
I hope that it is.
It is,
it is absolutely the right thing to do.
Um,
and,
uh,
and as we talk about reengaging with the world,
um,
and we vitalizing are,
are multilateralist traditions as a country,
we,
we certainly need to understand that our absence from the arms trade treaty and
the reputation in many instances of our mining sector and some of the violations
of human rights and,
and a and labor violations and in relation to that,
that has really thrown some of our credibility into question.
And,
and so if we really want to get there,
if you want to still be seen as that strong,
vibrant,
uh,
ethical force in the world,
then we do have to get some of these other pieces in order.
So hopefully they'll see that as one in the same,
we have a lot of good intentions as a nation.
We need to start actually acting on them.
Yeah.
We've made some strides though.
Monica,
could you ask just cause there are people on on VC.
Yeah.
And what was the reasoning for missing eat for missing the first opportunity to,
it was under the last government,
the Harper government.
So we,
and we,
they did not sign the arms trade treaty when they had that opportunity.
And in fact,
uh,
the domestic gun lobby and Canada,
I did a pretty good job even though it has nothing to do with domestic gun
ownership and they did a pretty good job of making people feel that it was,
um,
you know,
an effort.
The NRA did the same in the United States and efforts to control,
uh,
domestic arms sales and use.
Thank you.
It's like anything else with the arms industry,
there's a lot more um,
propaganda and irrational thinking out there on this subject.
Then there is fact,
I'm and honest appraisal
and you have a very small number of interests both numerically and monetarily
who seem to hold the entire agenda hostage.
And the u s the huge debate going on.
I think they may actually still be debating in Congress.
They had a filibuster all,
all night.
Um,
the majority of Americans support efforts like this,
the majority of Canadian support efforts like this,
but a tiny group of vested interests can block that legislation.
How important do you think political activism is on the part of individuals
writing to our members of parliament?
Writing to our senators,
writing to our,
our,
um,
Congress people.
I think it's absolutely critical.
Uh,
uh,
politicians are swayed by public opinion and
strongly worded letters
and navy and when it isn't concerned about reelection.
So if you have enough people who are mounting an opposition to a particular
policy,
a particular point of view,
politicians are going to listen to that.
Part of the reason why the arms trade treaty didn't get signed is that there
simply wasn't enough public interest or concern or outcry,
um,
that we hadn't signed it yet.
And,
and that's a great shape.
And I think the same applies to the United States when you have the majority of
Americans who are at least,
uh,
committed to introducing certain aspects of gun control legislation around
particularly semiautomatic weapon weapons,
like the Ar 15,
um,
people who are on a terrorist watch list.
And they were talking about people,
people who have a,
a very clear mental health history,
um,
that would be deemed to be high risk.
I mean,
that is,
that is a public
safe on the terrorist.
No flight.
People on the terrorist,
no Phyliss can mean that is a public safety issue.
And um,
and they,
they are right to be shaming and embarrassing those legislators who cannot get
behind what the majority of Americans want.
Yeah.
And even here in Canada,
we had a,
uh,
a member of parliament who was making the case Vr ar 15 is a perfectly safe
device,
uh,
when handled properly.
So it was heroin.
So it was plutonium.
We only do you have that either.
Um,
and,
and also made the case that it's a great deer hunting weapon.
I've never seen anybody go hunting with him with an ar 15
and that's a great point.
And I would add to that too,
you know,
people will often say,
well,
if people want to kill each other,
they're going to find a way.
Um,
and they will cite different,
different,
uh,
wars around the world in which,
you know,
machetes were using other things too to a slaughter,
a hundreds of thousands of people.
But the truth is that in almost every instance,
it's having access to those small weapons that in fact also facilitated that,
that particular slaughter.
Because usually it's people with arms that are able to then move the populations
or control or prevent anybody who is trying to stop that from happening.
So the two often go hand in hand
and the case we're making it easier isn't a good idea,
right?
No,
no.
Yeah.
They might find a way,
but there's not a lot of kids who get killed by stray strangling.
Well,
that's not,
that's not a thing.
That's right.
And,
and you,
you know,
you have a much better chance of,
uh,
of being able to stop that person.
The more,
the more automatic that weapon is,
the more violent that weapon is,
the greater the destruction.
Excellent.
Any other audience questions or Dory questions?
Yeah.
Um,
so here at Google we have employee resource groups of which the largest is a
women at Google.
Uh,
there's a pretty strong chapter in our office led by Margot here.
Um,
and Nancy,
he's sitting right next to her.
Um,
so the first time that I saw you speak was at the WXN summit in November.
You were the keynote at the awards gala that night,
and we were all just like in love with you after that.
We thought you had a lot of great perspective on life in general.
And what I loved about the way that you spoke was that it was not,
you know,
I'm speaking to the girls.
This is like among us girls,
like you just had a great perspective in life in general.
Um,
that being said,
I think you had a lot to say about what it's like being in your role and going
through your life,
being you,
being a woman,
and having some of the barriers that you did.
So I'd love if you could kind of talk about that for this group.
Well thank you.
It's nice to see you again.
Look,
there's,
there's no question that would be a woman.
And doing this kind of work comes with its own set of challenges.
And I were in environments around the world where there's a tremendous amount
of,
of sexual violence,
a huge amount of harassment.
I mean,
I've personally experienced a great deal of that myself.
Um,
and,
and risk and then trying to juggle everything I never used.
The word balance balance for me is always such a cliche because I,
without exaggeration,
wake up every day and deal with what's on fire and if I can put out those fires
that has a banner day for me.
So balance I think is something that is sort of a mythology.
It's where you find,
you find balance where you find leprechauns and Rainbow Colored Unicorns,
I'm fabulous.
But uh,
you know,
so that it does come with,
with certain risks.
And,
and for me,
the only way that I've discovered too to contend with that is just to stare them
down,
you know,
to,
to get back up and to get back in there and,
uh,
and to persevere,
to defy.
And,
and I've been doing that my in my entire life,
you know,
and,
and you get that from the time as a girl,
from the time that you're,
you know,
you're this big,
right?
Girls can't play in the park.
Girls can't do this.
Girls can't do that.
What girls can do those things and girls are doing those things and we're going
to show you that we can do the better.
Um,
and,
uh,
and that's the message that I try to convey to young women all the time,
which is to,
um,
speak up,
to speak out,
to be undaunted two,
don't look for,
uh,
don't seek permissions in my,
in my opinion,
permissions are only sought by those who lack imagination.
Um,
and,
and don't be afraid to,
to,
to screw up.
And don't worry so much about whether people like you,
you know,
I'm sure there's an entire fleet of people out there who can't stand me.
And,
uh,
I know there is because the fact I hear from the one Twitter quite often,
especially some of those Nra folks,
they love me.
Um,
and,
and I think that,
you know,
we,
we don't hear enough.
I really women's voices.
Um,
and,
and we don't role model enough and we don't mentor that enough,
I think.
And,
uh,
and so for all of you here is women who are in the tech industry.
I think it's really incumbent on you to,
um,
to be out there and to,
to be talking about your experiences and to be getting other young women,
uh,
involved and to be defined those stereotypes.
Because when I first started in this work,
uh,
there were hardly any women going in and out of war zones.
There were hardly any of them,
you know,
was more,
was always seen as traditionally a male domain.
And now I'm astonished every time I walk into the office and we have so many
more women in our office than we do men.
And they were definitely the visible minority in our office.
And,
uh,
and that's,
that's great.
You know,
that is great,
especially when you're talking about working with civilians in war zones that
usually the ones who are most impacted,
um,
by war are civilians,
primarily women and children.
So having women on the front lines of those conversations,
trying to do something about it is,
is critical to our success and to eventually eradicating the problem.
Um,
you're in your book,
in the intro you mentioned that you don't think that war is a,
uh,
part of the human condition and that there is hope after reading it and
listening to your Ted Talk.
I'm just struck by how complicated these issues are.
What keeps you hopeful?
A couple of things.
Um,
but,
but I would say I don't fear that complexity.
I think that part of it is,
um,
there aren't always easy fixes and easy answers and,
and we mislead people when we pretend that that isn't true
despite what campaign promises
hi one campaign promises are out there.
Right.
Um,
and I think that for all of us as,
as we move forward,
it is important to be more sophisticated around what works and what doesn't work
and,
and that it is complicated and it's time for us to embrace that complexity.
So that I would say sort of partly that.
But for me,
ultimately what I find most helpful is that we are,
um,
every day at war child in our office,
uh,
we have,
we are surrounded by people who are a testament to what can be done with a
compassion and some ingenuity,
some ingenuity and,
and concern and a sense of strong global citizenship.
You know,
we hear from people who are in our programs,
uh,
where it really has changed their lives.
We hear from staff who run those programs,
who helped build those programs,
uh,
just how important our work is to their community and how,
how respected they feel and how engaged they feel.
Um,
and,
and that ours is a true partnership.
You know,
that we're not coming in and telling them what to do,
but we're asking them what they want to do,
um,
and,
and that,
that they feel valued in that process.
And so whenever I find myself extremely frustrated,
which,
which is often,
and it's never about the things that you would expect,
I mean we're dealing with security situations all the time,
which are very frustrating,
but it's often seeing a fantastic program like the one we have in eastern Congo
that survives on,
on fuse because it's so hard to mobilize public interest for that war.
Now that it's almost 20 years old,
uh,
despite how devastating it has been.
That's the stuff that keeps me up at night.
Um,
but,
but I get up and I pushed through that sense of cynicism and,
and frustration.
Um,
because people depend on us and it seems very,
it always has seemed very self indulgent to me to say,
Oh,
this work is exhausting and I want to do it anymore.
I mean,
we've got people around the world that,
that gets shot at on their way to work,
whose children can't go more than two blocks because there'll be raped.
Um,
in South Sudan where all of our,
our,
our staff and program partners had to flee to the refugee camps.
Um,
and within two days of them arriving at the refugee camps,
they say,
we're going to keep going.
And we went,
well,
hang on a second.
We're still trying to figure out where the stuff is.
The whole office has been burned and torched.
And later they're like,
no,
we're here now.
We're going to go.
Um,
and,
and that is extraordinary and it's breathtaking when you experience it and,
um,
and it,
you know,
it makes me really hopeful and,
uh,
and that's why I get up every day.
That's fantastic.
Um,
Vera,
how are we doing for time?
MMM.
Okay.
Excellent.
So in that case,
um,
I'm going to leave it on that.
Uh,
everyone here.
Um,
I encourage you to take a Samantha's a request.
Seriously.
We have a I'd donation matching program at Google.
You can set it up so that part of your,
every single paycheck goes to an organization like war child to help in conflict
zones that people may have forgotten about,
that they're no longer,
no longer in the headlines.
Right?
Right.
Though,
strongly worded letters to your members of parliament,
um,
try to make that difference.
Uh,
and we have some books I think at the back,
um,
uh damn nations.
Fantastic.
A fantastic read and definitely check out the Ted talk as well on ted.com.
Thanks everyone.
Thank you.
Yeah.